what's going on there reject nation so
looks like that uh they're not waiting
until super bowl sunday to unveil some
spots we got two new spots here for
sonic the hedgehog heart dose today
leave a like that would be very much
appreciated other than that let's just
swing into action and see what they got
in store for us today
[Music]
and here we go
get your heart out sean
white gotta get some snowboard action
papa's got a brand new stash
oh lord there are two of them now
just get it married
way more than two
do i look like i need your power
no
sonic the hedgehog too it's called snow
on game day
it all comes down to heads or
tails
see what we did there the showdown
begins
what did they do
sonic the hedgehog
you're no match for me
this is the moment to be the big hero
[Music]
oh great the winter soldiers
it is my destiny to destroy you awesome
not harder
that wasn't too bad damn whoa
sonic the hedgehog to april 8th sweet
digs thank you there's a good amount of
stuff in there so i'll look at what is
that the the the death egg
what's the death egg john you're the
sonic expert i mean it's it's a big mech
suit that's made to look like dr
robotnik that has a whole bunch of
weaponry on it it goes under a number of
different names but that's probably the
most prolific and what are some of the
names john i mean you can call it like
the egghead mac or the death egg there's
so many rich styles for this big-ass
robot machine no i mean death egg is
probably the most ubiquitous term yet
and i mean to see it in like full
pacific rim circa sonic the hedgehog
scale i think is gonna be especially fun
plus they brought in snowboarding there
have been several sonic snowboarding
games which i'm sure is the one thing
everybody was really really upset was
missing from the first movie because as
we all know what's the first thing you
think of when you think of sonic
snowboarding aren't there levels in like
one of the sonic games maybe a couple of
them are there levels
were there like actual they're actually
like snowboarding like you do cool
tricks oh that's awesome sporting stuff
yeah man my sonic expert over here
just i'm loving all the expertise man
and then what was going on with the
master emerald there is that uh the
chaos
what's that what's that island uh you
know i mean it's it's part of the sonic
realm i couldn't tell you for absolute
certain what the temple is called the
the lore in that aspect i'm gonna have
to go and refresh myself cause it's been
a decade since i played what sonic 2 or
whatever the
some of this is ripped directly out of
when i'm researching after the first
trailer came out because i'm not a sonic
expert that i was told that that could
be angel island that they will go to i
mean that's i wasn't told this could be
angel island
they would probably go to angel island
here it would make a lot of sense for
that to happen granted i don't remember
what angel island is john take it away
don't have a great like lore
recollection to tell you exactly what
you're supposed to be the sonic expert
why would you go on youtube if you don't
know every single thing about everything
that we ever talk about i regret the day
that i claimed being the sonic expert
you should be embarrassed about yourself
i'm always embarrassed that's my secret
cap i'm always embarrassed about myself
well this looks a lot better the first
trailer already told me that this is
going to be better than the first sonic
movie and this this trailer just further
solidifies that what i'm really
appreciating about this is a lot of
times with franchises such as sonic they
often do a thing where it's like yeah we
have sonic who's not human so let's
focus on the humans and which is the
first movie did and that made a lot of
money and it was really satisfying for
many audiences what i'm loving about the
direction here is it seems like they're
really pushing the humans off to the
side like if okay that girl the girl
who's getting married she was she the
sister in the first movie sister or
cousin yeah something like that i don't
remember but looks like she's getting
married so they probably have to go to
the wedding after they go to the wedding
the humans will be off dealing with that
did they establish the first church
james marsden and and tikka sumter
getting married and then she's just
there oh i looked like she was getting
married as she might be i'm not sure
someone who's getting married and as
someone who's in a wedding this weekend
i will come back to you guys and confirm
whether or not there will be an addendum
to this video explaining the wardrobe
choice for that particular moment
regardless what they're doing such a
good job at promoting here is that this
really feels like it's going to be
centrally focused on knuckles tails and
sonic and of course dr robotnik so with
that you're getting all these like video
game references like the levels getting
the death egg all these things brought
to life here that really feel like
they're honoring the game even more so
because it's just funny coming out of
the first sonic movie when they
announced sonic 2 i didn't think that
they would lean so heavily into the
direction that they are now taking with
this uh follow-up movie because this
looks like epic it looks like epic and
funny and knuckles looks intense jim
carrey likes feels like he's blending in
a lot better it doesn't feel like the
jim carrey show which is how like the
first trailer made it feel which is what
you got to do for your first movie
establish your main protagonist your
main antagonist so the fact that we're
getting the death egg here seems like we
would probably get our showdown as you
saw with the master emerald there
between knuckles and sonic at first then
you would go into the the big fight with
the mecca death egg yeah yeah when
everyone realizes that ah robotnik
didn't have solid intent after all or at
least when knuckles realizes that and
eventually comes around to help the team
and whatnot but yeah i love the sense of
adventure that they're throwing up here
especially the angel island stuff looks
like an indiana jones movie meet sonic
which a lot of those old sonic levels
lend themselves to that kind of realm
anyway even if they're not exactly that
and uh you know i mean we got a couple
of little you know there's a winter
soldier reference i'm sure there's going
to be a bunch of like other fun like
sci-fi and other movie video game type
references or things like that and like
you said it it almost feels like the
opposite of what you would imagine the
stereotype to be whereas in the first
one it's like guy he's not human we're
in the human world now it feels like the
human world would be like the first act
jumping off point and then we'll pretty
soon leave there and go even further
down yeah the fantastical sonic world
rabbit hole and that's exciting to me it
feels like this will almost bridge
further the gap between being a live
action and just a big scale animated
sonic movie yeah that's true all right
guys that everything featured here that
was brand new what was your favorite
element here are you still mainly just
looking forward to knuckles i feel
that's gonna be a hell of a showdown
between the two of them subscribe click
that notification bell hit that like
button last but not least let's do it
maria hammond if i could travel through
rings at super speed i would immediately
go to your place uh just yesterday you
sent olivia a gift and i mean we just
got it thanks for picking that up by the
way after uh we opened it uh literally i
was i myself was shocked at what you had
delivered did a video on i haven't put
it up yet but like olivia's favorite
movie is gone with the wind and then
through a variety of situations maria
managed to actually attain the original
screenplay for
god with the wind to unpack it and see
that it's not some like fresh print
vintage in the way it is it was so
surprised even for me i'm like this is
for olivia but even i'm like that is
insane so thank you for being the
awesome person that you are because that
that gift even for for my eyes was
astonishing to behold thank you